Hello, everybody.
This is Dr. Plummer,
and this is a lecture
on hematopoiesis.
We did the histology
of blood, and that
was all in the peripheral
blood. This is what
happens before the
mature blood cells in
the peripheral blood
come out. They hang
out in the marrow,
and they are immature.
And this is important
to know because
understanding hematopoiesis
helps you understand
leukemias, which we
will discuss later on
in the spring. So
these are the session
objectives, which you
can read on your own.
They're also in the CPG,
and this is basically
the outline that
we're going to follow.
Now, I don't
go a lot into
lymphopoiesis.
You'll see why.
It's more relevant to
the immunology lectures,
so I'm not going to
go much into that.
We've already discussed
B cells, T cells and
NK cells and how the
T cells mature in the
thymus and the B cells
in the bone marrow.
So that we're not going
to go over in a big
way. So where does
hematopoiesis occur? I've
kind of already said
it, it's in the marrow
but not until the fetus
is born. The fetus
at about third week
of gestation in the
yolk ***, that's where
the blood islands are.
Then as the fetus
grows there's the liver
phase which is
mostly erythropoiesis
which means red blood
cells and by the second
trimester most of
the hematopoiesis or
the development of
cells happens in the
bone marrow in the
infant all bones uh are
have bone marrow
and in adults um the
bone marrow the red
bone marrow which i'll
talk about in a second
is mostly in the
flat bones proximal
femur often if If you
do a bone marrow
biopsy, they do it in
the hip bone or sometimes
the sternum even
because that's the
best area to get it.
So just a quick note
on red marrow and
yellow marrow. Red
marrow is very, very
vascular and it's
got the sinusoids and
it's got all the
stem cells, the
hematopoietic stem
cells, the cells that are
going to become mature
in the peripheral
blood. This is where
blood cells form and
it also has the stem
cells as I said.
The yellow marrow is
basically adipocytes
or fat and as you get
older more and more
adipose tissue takes
up the marrow as you
can see in this diagram
from 0 to 16 years.
So by 16 most of the
marrow is all at the
end not really in the
middle of the bone and
this is usually in
newborns it's actually
in newborns it's almost
all red and as they
get older it becomes
yellow. Here's another
chart if you want
to look at it. This
is the same thing
basically but as an adult
as a person develops
an adult has less
red bone marrow than
yellow okay and the
yellow has to do
with adipose tissue.
Now what is bone
marrow? Now I put up
histology pictures
and people panic. You
shouldn't do that because
I don't, I usually
describe them pretty
well. What you're
looking at here on the
upper left is a bone
marrow biopsy. And
those pink things, those
really bright pink
things with the stars
on them, as you can
see with my arrow,
are bone spicules.
That's bone. And in
between all that is
marrow. Now, why is this
marrow, why does this
marrow have all these
holes in it? That's
fat. That's the adipose
tissue. And the other
stuff is the hematopoietic
elements. Now,
when you go on high
power down in the lower
right hand corner,
you can tell you have
the big holes, which
are fat, and you've got
a whole bunch of just
cells of all different
types. I can't tell
you necessarily what
they are at this
point. I can tell these,
you'll learn a little
bit later, this one
here at about 12 o'clock
and here, Those are
megakaryocytes. They
are precursors to
platelets. And the reason
why I know that is
because of the term
megakaryocyte. They're
huge. You can easily
see them amongst the
other elements. But don't
worry right now about
identifying them.
When you look at a
normal bone marrow, you
should see a three-cell
lineage, a tri-lineage.
What do we mean by
that? We mean that
we should see a myeloid
or white cell lineage,
a erythroid or red
blood cell lineage,
and a platelet or
megakaryacidic lineage. So
in this one I can easily
see the megakaryacidic
ones. That's these
big ones here that
are kind of pink. Those
are megakaryacidic.
The little darker blue,
those are probably
erythroid, I'm sorry,
yeah, erythroid
precursors. These
are the ones who will
eventually become red
blood cells. And then
the other cells in
between are most likely
white blood cell
precursors. And you
even see some down
here that are mature,
are getting mature to
be neutrophils. But
again, don't try to
recognize and just
realize that when
somebody looks at a bone
marrow, that's what they
want to normally see.
And that's what you're
not going to see
in cases like leukemia
or lymphoma so that
was a bone marrow
biopsy this when they do
a biopsy they also
do a smear so you can
kind of see more of the
cells a different way
and again you can
still see fat in the
smear these this round
um kind of looks like
a snowman in there
uh these little dots
that are very blue are
probably the erythroid
precursors we've got
a big megakaryocyte
right here and we have
a lot of white cell
precursors okay and
we'll go through what
they are but we have
a trilineage marrow.
So this talks about the
cellularity of a marrow.
Usually we want a
normal cellular marrow
for age, and I'll
teach you how to figure
that out in a second.
But when there's
too many cells, when
you don't see any fat
at all, that is
considered hypercellular,
and that's over here
on the right. When
there's too much fat
and not enough cells,
it's hypocellular.
And when there's
really not many cells
at all except for fat
is aplastic. Now
this also varies with
age but this is just
an idea about what you
look at when you look
at a bone marrow.
So normally in the
bone marrow, and we're
talking about adults
now, there's blood
vessels, sinusoids
where the red blood
cells go, and all the
hematopoietic cells.
I talked about the
trilineage maturation.
You should see a
trilineage maturation in
the myeloid or white
blood cell series,
erythroid, and
megakaryacidic lines.
Now, cellularity
does change with age,
and a rough, rough
estimate is taking
your age, subtracting
it from 100, and
then adding plus
or minus 10%. What
does that mean? So,
if I'm 50 years old,
100 minus 50 is 50. So,
my cellularity should
be, as it shows down
there on the bottom
bullet 50 percent but
if I'm 40 or 60 that's
okay too so it should
range from 40 to 60
percent to be considered
normal anything less
than that would be
hypo anything more than
that would be hyper for
some reason so let's
start with the whole
the beginning as we
always do hematopoiesis
there is a theory a
monophyletic theory if
you will that all blood
cells arise from a
common cell, a common
stem cell, and it's
called the pluripotential
stem cell. From there,
that gives rise to
all the other stem cells,
the progenitor stem
cells. Note that the
pluripotential stem
cell is the beginning
and the progenitors are
after. Stem cells are
usually defined by the
presence of CD34
positive surface marker
protein. We discussed a
little bit in histology
what a cluster of
differentiation means.
So if the bone marrow
is not working,
say you have metastatic
disease in the
bone marrow or
doesn't work for some
reason on the drug,
what happens is
something called
extramedullary hematopoiesis.
Medullary refers
to the bone
marrow, so it's outside
the bone marrow.
This happens when
the bone marrow can't
meet the demands for
blood cell production.
Where does this
happen? Usually
in the liver you
can see it, in
the spleen, even
in lymph nodes.
And you can see this
in many different
diseases, as it
says here, some
hemoglobinopathy,
some cancers, and
myoperative disorders.
But just realize
that marrow can
develop in the adult
outside the bone,
usually only in
pathological cases or
something is wrong.
Okay, this is where
it gets a little bit
complicated, and
I'm going to try to
walk you through
this. The progenitor
stem cell is the colony
forming unit. This
is the one after
the pluripotential.
Now the myeloid
lineage, I'm not
saying cell, the
myeloid lineage is a
little confusing
because it means
everything from
granulocytes, monocytes,
erythrocytes, and
megakaryocytes.
And their CFU or colony
for human is known
as GEMM, which refers
to granulocytes and
erythrocytes and
megakaryocytes and monocytes.
From here we differentiate
into about five
different ones,
CUFGM, CUFE, and these
all become mature
granulocytes, monocytes,
eosinophils,
platelets, or here's an
eosinophil, I'm sorry,
that's an erythroid,
E is for erythroid
and basophil.
And then all by
itself is the lymphoid
lineage, T-cells and
B-cells, which form
colony-forming units
dash L. Now this is
just a table of what
I just said, but let's
go through this a
little bit more. I went
through it pretty
quickly. This is a
very complex chart. It's
the hematopoietocarchy,
but it's very,
very important. So
if you look up at the
upper left here, this
is the pluripotential
stem cell, okay?
And that's all in the
way on the upper left.
This would be CD3-4
positive, most likely.
That gives rise
to the myeloid
stem cell, which
is right here,
and the lymphoid
stem cell.
And those are
progenitor stem cells.
They're essentially
the same thing as
colony forming units.
They're progenitor
stem cells. So don't
get confused with
the terminology.
The progenitor cells
are basically the
colony-forming units.
And essentially, this
myeloid stem cell is
what I called before
colony-forming unit, or
C-F-U-E-G-E-M-M. It's
not in this diagram,
but we can go back
one, and you can see
that I talked about C-U
-F-G-E-M. and look we're
differentiating to
five different things
so first let me start
with the lymphoid
because that's the easiest
you have the lymphoid
stem cell it's not
labeled as a cful and
eventually it develops
into t and b lymphocytes
under the influence
of various cytokines
and colony stimulating
factors that we'll
talk about lymphoblasts
any blasts at all
those are the earliest
precursors and then
eventually they become
mature lymphocytes.
Now separately under
the influence of
different colony
stimulating factors you have
which are CSFs, colony
stimulating factors,
and growth factors
in cytokines. We
start here with the
myeloid cell which I
already said is basically
CFU-GEMM right here
in the middle. Okay
and that goes to five
paths really. um what
if you see one two
three four five um
basically um you get
the g um let's go
through this um you you
get five paths g f cfu
gm cfu e o little o
which is eosinophils
cfu b cfu meg and cfu
e that's all these
cfu's here okay and
it all comes from this
one progenitor cell
So let's start with the
CFU-GM up here. This
is the CFU-GM, right?
This is going to
become both the granulocytic
and the monocytic
series. So the monocytic
series is easy.
We're going to go
through it. There's like
three stages and
basically it's a monocyte
in the blood and a
macrophage in tissue.
And then the myelocyte
or the granulocytes
will follow this
pattern. They can become
neutrophils or eosinophils
or basophils. And
we'll talk more about
that in a little
bit. Then there's the
fourth kind, which is
the megakaryocyte CFU,
which can become a
megakaryoblast and then
becomes a megakaryocyte
and eventually
becomes platelets. And
then finally, the fifth
one, the erythroid,
which becomes a bred
blood cell eventually.
Now, these things
all happen because
there are factors,
growth factors in
cytokines working on
that. So the CFUGM,
which comes from
the CFUGEMM,
eventually leads
to the formation
of mature
granulocytes and
monocytes, and that's
under different
influences like a CSF,
GM, and IL-3, etc. And
we'll go into that in
the next few slides.
Monoblasts are
pretty easy. They
give rise to
mature monocytes.
The C-F-U-E-O also
becomes a myeloblast,
but eventually,
see if you all look
here, these are all
myeloblasts, these
three, But eventually,
one is a neutrophil,
eosinophil, and
basophilic cell.
Blasts of any type
can be seen in the
bone marrow without
the help of CD stains.
Though you use the
CD stains by flow
cytometry, they're
very helpful in
telling what kind of
blasts. Because all
blasts pretty much
look the same to the
***** eye. Whether
they are a myeloblast,
and here we are
in this column.
megacaryoblast myeloblast
proerithroblast
all these if you look
under the microscope
except for maybe the
megacaryoblast they
all look pretty much
the same and that's why
we need the cd
designation okay let's go
through this that's
the overall view and
let's go follow through
so like i said this
doesn't happen by
itself there are growth
factors and cytokines
and things that help
them go through this
development this
maturation basically
we have hematopoietic
growth factors and just
to be confusing they
call them colony
stimulating factors not
CFUs which are calling
forming units but
colony stimulating factors
these are basically
cytokines and they
stimulate proliferation
of progenitor and
other precursor cells
and they what they
do is they mature the
cells they differentiate
mature them along
their lineage a cytokine
is described as a
small protein involved
in cell signaling.
There are three types
of growth factors.
Well, there are a
lot. I shouldn't say
there are three. There
are a lot of types
of growth factors,
but talking for
this lecture, all of
these are cytokines.
CSF,
interleukin is one,
and two that are
important that I
want you to remember,
and I'll go through
them, erythropoietin
And as you can
imagine, those growth
factors are very
important in the
development of red
blood cells and
in the development
of platelets.
Again, this is a
big chart with a
lot of words. Do
not memorize it.
Memorization is not
going to be it here.
I put some things in
red because these are
the most important.
Again, on the bottom,
EPO, TPO, these are what
causes differentiation
into red blood
cells and platelets.
The EPO is
produced by the
kidney, and the
TPO is produced by
both the kidney
and the liver.
Okay, so let's start
with the granulocytic.
Okay, we're going
to start now
with the granulocytic.
Like I said,
we're not talking
about lymphocytes.
So granulocytes,
which basically we're
going to talk about
the neutrophils,
the basophils, and
the eosinophils.
So first, the
neutrophils.
It's a very complex
hierarchy, the first
one being the myeloblast.
and it is like i
said looks like any
other blast you do not
have to memorize these
cd surface markers
all it shows is that
as it differentiates
it gets more more
cd markers and and
sometimes gets rid of
them and you you usually
see prominent nuclei
the next step is the
promylocyte and this
is an important one
and i'll tell you
what this one you can
really see nicely uh
because they have big
thick granules and
this is important in a
leukemia that we'll
talk about called acute
promyelocytic leukemia.
These are large
cells that have primary
granules. Then the
myelocyte where you
have secondary granules
and the metamylocyte.
What's the difference
between the two? Well
a little that the
nucleus becomes a
little indented, kidney
bean shaped it's called,
and between Between
these two, the late
myelocyte and the early
metamyelocyte, that's
when the cell says,
oh, I think I'll be a
neutrophil, or oh, I
think I'll be a basophil,
or an eosinophil.
But here we're
going through
just for the neutrophil.
From the metamyelocyte,
you get the band
form. Now, why did I put
two red stars by these
two? Because these
can be seen in the
peripheral blood. this
is all in the marrow but
and these can be seen
in the peripheral blood
the band form also
called a stab form
normally like if there's
a high white count
somebody has a high
infection you will have
neutrophils and if they're
really high they will
have bands and the
band form is different
than the metamylocyte
because the metamylocyte
has a little bit more
granules and it's
not as horseshoe shaped
and usually though
people don't have bands
in there You know,
it's only when they
have a severe form of
infection or severe white
granulocytic release.
Okay, so this is what
it looks like in real
life. Okay, so we're
going from upper
left across and then
upper and then go down
to upper left and
across. So myeloblast,
this, like I said,
is a blast. Look how
big the nucleus
is and it's got a
nucleic. A lot of
blasts, other than the
megakaryoblast,
will look like this.
So it would be hard
to say what it is
unless you do see
the differentiation.
The promyelocyte
has a lot of
granules. It still
has a pretty big
nucleus, but it has
a lot of granules,
and they're
primarily granules.
As it develops further,
the myelocytes,
the nucleus becomes
a little bit
more dense, a little
smaller. and specific
granules begin
to form, specific
meaning specific to
that granulocyte.
Metamolocyte, that's
where you really
start, you really do
then see the neutrophil,
eosinophil, and
basophil more
definitely because of
the specific granules.
And the band, as I
mentioned, and
the segment.
There's a lot of words
for this polymorph
or nuclear cell. You can
call it a neutrophil,
which I prefer, or a
PMN, or polymorphic
nuclear cell, or segments,
whatever you want
to call it. But that is
the mature neutrophil
granulocyte that
should be in the bone.
Again, I told you
bands can sometimes
be called stabs.
That's an old
historical term.
If you see that, I
don't think they
do that anymore.
And remember that
mature PMNs should have
two to four lobes. so
what if they don't want
to become neutrophils
well they go the same
path but at the myelocyte
and metamyelocyte
stage that's when they
become eosinophilic
same thing for basophilic
so the take-home
message here is in
red you can't tell the
difference between
eosinophilic or basophilic
or neutrophilic
precursors at least
morphologically until the
late myelocytic or the
early metamyelocytic
stage and that's
because that's when the
specific granules appear
so if you're ever on
a question i would
pick if it had hopefully
hopefully they wouldn't
put myelocyte
metamyelocyte in the same
because that's kind
of difficult and you
could argue that oh
yeah it happens in the
late myelocyte but early
myelocyte but if you
want to be really sure
and they say you can
see all the specific
granules definitely
it's made its commitment
to be a neutrophil,
an eosinophil, or a
basophil, then the
metamyelocyte stage is
probably where that is.
And this is just
basically a schematic of
what I've been talking
about because I
like to repeat myself,
but we don't start
here from the blast,
okay? We start from the
promyelocytes with a
lot of granules, and
we see that basically
they can become
basophils, neutrophils,
or eosinophils, and
they all have the
same kind of pathways.
The monoblasts are
very simple. They
become promonocytes
and then they become
monocytes. Now
remember monocytes are
called macrophages
in tissue and the
differentiation and
growth of the CFU
-GM into monocytes
is stimulated by
these three things
that you don't have
to necessarily memorize
but interleukin
always comes up
like interleukin-3.
The CSF is the factor
that I was talking about.
In the bone marrow
you have monoblasts
and promonocytes.
You should
not have that in the
peripheral blood.
You should have
just monocytes.
Monocytes stay in the
circulation for about
16 hours and then
go into tissues and
become macrophages. The
other word for macrophages,
in case you hear
it, is histiocytes.
So here's a picture
of a monocyte. It
almost looks like,
you know, you're going
to tell me, well,
that looks like a
band or a metal, but
it is a monocyte.
And how can you
tell? Well, You do
CD many times, and
also because it
has a bigger
cytoplasm. You don't
really see granules
in here, and that's
how you can tell
most of the time.
So monocytes only
circulate for a few
hours, and then they
go into their tissues,
as we discussed in
histology, where
they become the
macrophages of the site.
Now, remember, every
site is different.
There's Langerhans
histiocytes in the skin.
There's Kupfer
cells that are
macrophages in the
liver, and we went
through that in
histology of blood.
Let's turn to
erythropoiesis or the
making of mature red
blood cells and here
you really need to
remember erythropoietin.
Yes there are other
growth factors
and signals CSF,
GM-CSF, IL-3 and 4.
This remember comes
from the CFU-GEMM
and becomes a
CFUE and their
hierarchy is a
little bit more
complicated. It's
pro-erythroblast
basophilic,
and it's called
basophilic not because
it's the basophilic
granules but
because it's blue
because basophilic
means blue,
polychromatophilic,
and a normoblast
which is also known
as a orthochromatophilic
erythroblast.
There are a lot of
different names.
I emphasize reticulocyte
because that is an
important cell to know
about. It's also got
another term don't
worry about these other
terms just remember
reticulocyte you can
normally have like
one to two percent of
reticulocytes in your
blood but if that number
goes up that means
your bone marrow is
producing and pulling up
pulling out or I should
say shoving out a
lot of precursors red
blood cell precursors and
that means something's
going on there's
some bleed you need
red blood cells so there
must be some bleeding
and of course the
mature cell is the
erythrocyte and this is
what this looks like.
Again you don't
need to necessarily
memorize these
different steps but
I do want you to
know a blast is a
blast. I mean
those are the baby
cells or embryonic
cells if you will.
And then as it becomes
a mature red blood
cell you go through here
at the polychromatic
erythroblast stage.
It's also known
by the way as an
arthrochromatic erythroblast
stage. don't worry
about that but what
you do want to worry
about is that this at
this point look how
smaller the cell is
it's much more pink
because you got a lot
more hemoglobin and
at this point you've
got a really compact
densely stained nucleus
and the nucleus comes
out and you get a
reticulocyte and
this is a really bad
picture because the
reticulocyte it looks like
it's really pink and
pale a reticulocyte
the nucleus is no
longer there remember
we do not have nucleated
red blood cells.
Certain animal species
do, but we do not.
And that's from the
reticulocyte you go
into mature erythrocyte.
So the reticulocyte
is the stage before
maturation and when
it's present in too
much abundance, it
means that the marrow
is producing too many
precursor red blood
cells. This is what
they look like in
reality. So again, this
pro-erythroblast looks
like the myeloblast
I showed you. You
can't really tell.
As you can tell
though they get
smaller, the nucleus
gets smaller, the
cells get smaller as
they mature. That's
true for pretty
much all of them,
all the lineages. Here
is the reticulocyte.
It has a little
stain sometimes they
have to stain it
and the erythrocyte.
These are hard to
tell a difference but
they use flow cytometry
to stain it and for
right now you don't
need to know that.
Finally the
thrombopoiesis, the
platelets. How
do they happen?
Remember, like RBCs,
that platelets do not
have a nucleus. They
are anucleate and they
come from the megakaryocyte.
Well, where does
a megakaryocyte come
from? It starts again
as a blast. Everything
starts as a blast.
Megakaryoblast,
then a pro
megakaryocyte, then
megakaryocyte, and
then platelets.
Why do we need
platelets? We're going
to talk about that
more later on, not
in this lecture, but
later on. You need
them for a primary
hemostatic plug.
It helps in when
bleeding. You need a
plug. It's not a
firm plug, but you
need that to help in
stopping bleeding.
The lifespan is about
10 days, and again,
this comes from the
C-F-U-G-M-M that
differentiated into the
C-F-U-M-E-G. And don't
forget thrombopoietin
in this one.
Thrombopoietin is important
in making platelets.
Oh, this is just,
okay, what I want
you, there's a
lot of words here,
but it's basically
what I just said.
Megakaryoblast, though,
I want you to know,
it's probably the
largest cell in the bone
marrow, and it does
not have, it has a
non-login nucleus, and
it's the thrombopoene
and other factors, but
I want you to remember
thrombopoene, that
causes the development
of megakaryocyte.
Now, how do platelets
come out? Megakaryocyte
is still a big
cell with nuclei, and
we know that platelets
or thrombocytes do
not have nuclei. Well,
the megakaryocyte has a
very complex lobulated
nucleus, multilobulated,
and if you
look at trans electron
microscopy or transmission
you will see that
the in the periphery
of the cytoplasm there
seems to be division
into small compartments
and these are
platelet demarcation
channels and that
basically looks like i
have a better picture
than this but this
is the schematic of
thrombopoiesis this is
where we start because
these are this this
is the multipotent
hemopoietic stem cell,
or a pluripotent, same
thing as pluripotent,
this is CD34 positive,
then we get the
progenitor cells,
and the ME, you
know, like the CFU
ME, this would be
the C-F-U-G-E-M-M.
So then we get the
megakaryoblast,
the promegakaryocyte, the
megakaryocyte,
and the platelets.
and when you look okay
this is what i mean
by mega i mean this
is a low power view
they're all over the
look at how big these are
easy to find easy to
find a little bit too
many in here so that may
mean that something's
going on when you
look at high power you
can see at the these
little things coming
off of them and those
are from the platelet
demarcation channels and
those are the platelets
and i wanted you to
see them at higher
power you can't really
see them in a bone
marrow but they do
exist and that's how the
platelets go out into
the peripheral blood.
I want to put up
this photo. I want to
tell you this is not
easy to recognize and
I don't expect you
all to recognize it.
I want you to know
you know what a
neutrophil is and a
red blood cell etc
but for example this
thing up here on
a 12 o'clock is a
monocyte that can
sometimes be very
confusing because it
may look like a band
of a neutrophil.
People who do this
do this for many many
years so I you know this
is hard to recognize.
The one big thing here
is this monocyte has
a more blue cytoplasm,
the nucleus is a
little bit bigger, and
in the bands you've got
a lot of little granules
in there and that
helps in differentiating
it. I'm not going
to make you differentiate
this on an exam.
So let's do some clinical
cases. What's the
importance of knowing
all this. So we have
a 63-year-old man who
was admitted with a
history of increasing
abdominal pain, three
days duration, and the
pain is mostly in the
right upper quadrant.
Now think about the
right upper quadrant. What
is there anatomically?
There's the liver,
but there's also
another organ underneath
which is called the
gallbladder. And he
comes in with white
blood cell count of 12
,000 which is elevated.
It should be between
4 and 10,000.
So clinically,
they suspect acute
cholecystitis, and they
do cholecystectomy.
They take out
his gallbladder.
So which of the white
cell lines would be
most likely be
elevated in this acute
infection of the
gallbladder? I think this
is really, really kind
of simple, but I'm
going to let you think
about it. You can
stop the tape and
think. But the answer
is B, as in boy,
neutrophils. That's
what's going to be most
likely be elevated.
Next.
What does the elevated
white blood
count represent?
Infection,
inflammation, stress, or
all of the above?
What do you think?
It could be infection.
This is an infection,
right? It's also
inflammation, and it's
also stress. So the
answer is D. D as in
David, all of the above
can cause an elevation
in the white blood
cell count. And certainly
in a person who's
undergoing surgery
for an acute case of
cholecystitis, they
will have that.
Here's another case of
a 36-year-old man who
has a six-day history
of gums that are
bleeding, and he has
abdominal pain in his
left upper quadrant.
Now think about what's
in the left upper quadrant.
That's the spleen.
He's also reporting
fevers, fatigue,
decrease appetite
weight loss which
is unintentional
about 10 pounds in
one month when he
gets examined they see
red swollen gingiva
or gums and the gums
are also hyperplastic
they're bigger than
usual his lymph nodes
in the submandibular
region are very tender
and there's a palpable
spleen normally
you cannot palpate
a spleen in a human
being unless they're
really, really, really
thin, but the point
is this is a problem
if you can palpate a
spleen in this man.
He has a white
count of 194
,000, okay? That's
not good. I told
you normal was
4 to 10,000,
and that white
count, and this white
count is from the
peripheral blood,
44% of blasts.
Should you have any
blasts in the
peripheral blood? No.
And therefore, 44% is
really, really alarming.
The platelet
count is very low.
Platelets should
be between 150 and
400,000. Here they're
12,000. And why
would the platelet
count be low?
When all these
blasts and all these
white cells, there's
a lot of them, are
taking over the
marrow, there is no
room for platelets
or for the erythroid
series. So people
often will have
anemia and a decrease
in platelet count.
This is a man
with leukemia.
This is what
gingival bleeding
and hyperplasia
looks like.
Which cell line
is responsible for
the symptoms of
the bleeding gums?
Think about this. Why
is this man bleeding?
He has a platelet
count of 12,000. That's
not enough. So B is the
answer. B as in boy.
What hormone or molecule
regulates platelet
production?
And I really
want you to just
know about
thrombopoietin.
Thrombopoietin
is the answer.
With his white count
being so high, would
you expect that he
would be able to
fight infections
better? I mean it makes
sense. He's got a
lot of white blood
cells and white blood
cells fight infections.
So why would he
get any infections?
Well because almost
half, 44% of them are
blasts and blasts are
babies they're not
adults they're if you
look at it that way
they cannot fight
infection they are useless
it's like sending
babies to the ward
they cannot do anything
it has to be the
mature neutrophil
that will fight off an
infection and when you
have all those blasts
you do not have a lot
of mature neutrophils
and so that's why
people with leukemias
will also get a lot
of infection now we
have a five-year-old
white female who's
brought to a pediatrician.
She has fever,
marked weakness,
pale, bone pain.
Why would she have
bone pain? Think
about that. And
bleeding from her
nose, epistaxis.
She has a history of
progressively increasing
fatigue and recurrent
infection. Okay,
this is like screaming
out something is
really wrong with this
five-year-old girl.
When they examine
her, there's bruising
over the skin. The
sternum is tender.
She has a large liver
and spleen and some
lymph node
***********. she has
lymphocytosis with 30
% blast and anemia now
lymphocytosis means
there's a lot a lot of
lymphocyte type cells
but 30% of them are
lymphoblasts and they
again crowd out the red
blood cells the precursors
and the platelets
which is why she is
having bruising and why
she has having anemia
and the leukemia has
so filled up her bone
marrow that she's
actually feeling bone pain
so this is a very fuzzy
slide and I'm sorry
but this is not nor
even for a five-year
-old and this is if you
looked at high power
this would be a lot of
blasts and with a lot of
blasts and very little
fat there would not
be many mature cells
that would be out in
the in the peripheral
blood so this is a
leukemia when you look at
higher power does this
look like what I showed
you earlier about the
tri-lineage maturation
no it look they all
look pretty much I
don't see a megakaryositin
site and I can't
really tell what they
are they all look pretty
much the same so it
looks like the white
blood cells here are
taking over so what is
lymphocytosis it just
means it's an increase
in lymphocytes okay and
when might what might
this girl why is she
presenting in bone
pain I already told you
her marrow is so full
stuffed with lymphoblasts
that and other cells
that she is feeling
the pain and it's in
her sternum apparently
the different types of
lymphocytes we discussed
t-cell b-cell and
um nk cell in children
most of the times it's
a b-cell lymphoma but
that's for another
uh chapter at another
time this is what
erythroid hyperplasia
looks like and you're like
okay sure dr bum
whatever you said but why
what i'm showing you is
all these little dots
blue black dots these
are erythroid precursors
there's way too many
of them way too many
they're taken over
you have to have that
nice yes you can see
the megakaryocytes yes
you can see the white
blood cells, but there's
still too many. Why
would this occur? Why
would you have a
rithroid hyperplasia? Why
would the bone marrow
make more red blood cell
precursors? And the
answer is because the
peripheral blood needs
them. It needs red
blood cells. And why
does it need red blood
cells? Because an anemia
is occurring. Either
it's bleeding, probably
a bleeding, occurring
a hemolytic bleed.
But the point is, the
RBC in the peripheral
blood is very low. The
person is anemic. They
need more red blood
cells. So the marrow
goes into hyperfunction
and just churns out
or tries to churn out
the red blood cells by
erythroid hyperplasia.
This is just a marrow
with, like I showed
you before, almost
nothing. This is
what happens with
radiation or chemo, When
they have to take a
marrow and basically
take all the cells
out so they can do
a bone marrow
transplant, this is what
it would look like.
There's nothing in
there, basically,
except bone spicules.
And even if you
look at hypothyroid,
there's a little
something here and there,
but these are not
really, I mean, these
are probably, these
red blood cells
probably came from
the peripheral blood
when they were taking
the marrow biopsy.
Oh, I have one
more case. I didn't
realize that. A three
-year-old boy presents
with a recent
history of hives and
wheezing after he
ate chocolate mousse.
So he's at 18 months
of age. He contacts
urticaria, which
is the same word as
hives, when he put
his hand into a cake
mix containing eggs.
So obviously, this
little boy has
problems of allergies.
He has a history of
chronic rhinitis,
nocturnal cough, eczema,
previous hospitalization
for recurrent
wheezing. So it sounds
like this child has
asthma and allergies.
So I'm kind of putting
up this to make a
point. Which of the cell
lines might you find
elevated in this boy?
Well,
you know,
technically anything
could be elevated,
but I'm talking
about somebody
with asthma and
allergies. So the
answer should be A,
eosinophils.
There are other
cell lines that
are associated
with allergy, but
we're not going to
go into that now.
okay you do not need
to memorize these
values you will eventually
get to know them
I believe on your
exams they're given to
you these are some more
definitions you may
want to look at just
to be familiar with
a verbiage and the
summary slides which I
always put at the end
references and your
lecture feedback form
I went through that
pretty quickly and I
don't want to overwhelm
you with all these
different names.
It's really kind of
like learning a foreign
language. The point
being is we are now in
the marrow producing
blood. And when I
mean blood, I mean red
blood cells, platelets,
and white blood
cells. And the marrow
has to function
correctly. If leukemia
happens and you have
a packed marrow with
blast, it's not going
to function correctly.
So these are the precursors
to all the mature
cells that we saw in
the histology lab.
If you have any
questions, please feel
free to email me.
Come to my office,
rockefeller306, and
I'll be happy to answer
them. Thank you
for your attention.